hey what's up mkbhd here
beats by dre what comes to mind when you
hear that name it might have been a
while maybe you think of uh
large overpriced headphones with way too
much bass or
maybe you think about like small sleek
earbuds for sports maybe
either way whether it's one of those or
something in between the arc
of how we got from these to these
is fascinating so one of the earliest
videos i ever did about
beats by dre was called the truth about
beats by dre
and you know i know pretty juicy
headline but this was back in 2014
when beats had a very different
reputation of high fashion
a very different set of products and a
very different
position as a company this week
beets just announced these new studio
buds and while i don't personally think
they're perfect
they're absolutely not the best at
anything
they do feel way more in line with the
rest of the headphone world now so
what happened a little history beats
started up in 2006 right
so the first eight years or so of their
existence
they built up a certain reputation with
their audio products
mainly their headphones which were a
stylish super cool
borderline fashion accessory and if you
did use them as headphones well
cool they had plenty of bass but audio
fidelity was not the number one concern
but these were the days when beats would
get
their headphones on as many of the heads
of the most influential celebrities and
athletes and pop stars as humanly
possible they were the kings of this
which made them super cool to anyone who
followed them or look up to these people
but it was also pretty ironic because
there's almost no chance anybody
who mixed and made music actually used
beats by dre at any point in that
process
they just didn't sound that great well i
should clarify uh they didn't sound
that good to audiophiles or people who
actually cared about sound quality or
accuracy
but to most people to most people uh
the boomy bass heavy profile of these
was actually a feature because
they were listening to bass heavy music
anyway and they were just listening for
fun
and so people were actually very willing
to pay extra
for headphones this cool that sounded
like that and extra money
they spent because this was the main
subject of my truth about beats by dre
video
but clearly beats spent way more on
marketing than they did on r d
and it paid off because they were able
to charge a lot
they were selling 2 3 400 even
500 headphones and that allowed them to
capture something like
70 of the high-end headphone market
which is wild
because beats buyers they'd never spend
500 bucks on
any other pair of headphones but beats
had just created this commanding
buying power this alert to them which
was super powerful
kind of like how tesla today can get
people who were never really into cars
to spend way more than they normally
would to get one so beats is eating up
premium market share they're making tons
of money this is around the time that
they get on apple's radar and so
apple at this point had not made any
wireless headphones at all
just the earphones that come in the box
with the iphone yeah
so uh after some weird dances with htc
and monster cable
apple ended up buying beats for three
billion dollars which today is actually
their still largest acquisition
ever so since that moment i've kept an
eye on beats
and the stuff that they've kept making
because beats has
continued making stuff because you know
any number of things can happen when
one huge company swallows up another
with an acquisition sometimes they do it
for
the talent sometimes they do it for the
portfolio of products or the technology
or just the name with the case of beats
there's a couple things one they
essentially turned
beats music streaming service into apple
music
and two they started making wireless
audio products they introduced air pods
in 2016
then airpods pro and home pod and
homepod mini
and airpods max but curiously as you've
probably noticed
beats kept making beats headphones
they kept the name they kept the logos
and everything and they kept sort of
running the company
beats by dre as if it's sort of now just
working closely with apple it actually
makes a lot of sense
beats was making a lot of money they
were making about a billion dollars a
year
with headphones when apple bought them
in 2014 and you don't just throw away
all that revenue
all that brand cache apple's not stupid
but once apple started making headphones
they made sure beats didn't directly
compete with
airpods like some of the other clones
that i've made a video on
linked below they more lived alongside
them
as a high fashion alternative type of
thing and it would be fine if customers
picked beats by dre on the shelf
next to the apple headphones because
they're all
it's all apple beat success is apple's
success so if you've followed
beats headphones since then they've
slowly toned down
their image a little bit and they've
actually toned down
their pricing a bit too uh but they've
they've definitely
amplified their headphone lineup so
their headphones started switching to
charging with
lightning ports instead of usb to match
the iphone they started adding
w1 and then h1 chips to instant pair
with apple products and they started
integrating more natively into the
iphones audio control features
basically they became better and better
alternative headphones
for the iphone which is cool more
options is always better
but they definitely lost a little bit of
their character a bit so that brings us
to this week when apple announced
these the new studio buzz these wireless
earbuds and these to me
these are the most interesting
headphones that they've released
since that apple acquisition because you
know of course you know there's more
features and things and tech has gotten
better since 2014
but with these suddenly they're trying
to be
dual native and work just as well
on android as the iphone
so right off the top android users are
overall a bit more price sensitive so
guess what
their pricing has gotten even more
competitive than ever these will go for
149 with active noise cancellation
now that's not cheap but that beats
airpods pro
that beats sony's mark fours and a lot
of others with anc
that's a pretty good price for earbuds
with anc now there's definitely still
some downsides i'll get to those in a
second but overall
i think they've done a pretty good job
and then there's actually even a couple
pretty big changes they've made for
android users that i didn't expect
number one
they switched to usbc on the case like i
said they were on this streak of
lightning chargers but
this makes sense of course for the
android crowd and the case itself is
pretty compact which is something
i can't say about some previous beats
earbuds so
this is getting down to just be a little
bit bigger than air pods and
i do like this matte red here though you
can also get them
in white or matte black but then number
two these headphones actually
don't have apple's h1 chip in them
so like i said they're trying to be dual
native
and feel the same on either iphone or
android right so
a lot of these h1 chip beats in the past
would work
amazingly well for the iphone they'd
have all these features they'd instant
pair
but then they'd be missing a bunch of
those features when you try to bluetooth
pair them
to an android phone so these these still
instant pair with the iphone
and plug into ios's native audio
controls but
they lack the icloud connected switching
so if you're someone who's switching
headphones between
an iphone and a mac and an ipad all the
time
these don't do that so these probably
aren't for you but now
they have an equally awesome and equally
quick pairing process
on android which is very much
appreciated so they connect to the beats
app
then you get all the same controls you
have your access to google assistant
the same control over noise cancellation
versus transparency mode
it's great these these are the first
beats in a while that i feel like i can
actually recommend
for android users and yes i did say
noise cancellation these studio buds use
their mics to deliver
active noise cancellation that at this
price is not super common
and it's decent of course it's it's best
with white noise
but it is not as strong as airpods pro
or sony's xm4s
but i believe it is better than
samsung's attempt with galaxy buds live
so a more popular newer feature you're
seeing on noise canceling headphones now
is transparency mode so using those
microphones that were used for noise
cancellation
to actually mix in real world sound
so i can long press on the button here
to switch between
noise cancellation and transparency and
the transparency mode on these
is okay basically airpods transparency
mode
is so good that it could literally fool
your brain into thinking
you're not wearing headphones like you
just hear everything and so
everything else kinda looks bad in
comparison to those but by comparison
these sound just a bit muffled so voices
aren't quite as clear and clean as you'd
like them to be
it's not terrible i mean you still hear
your environment so if you're out
walking in the streets
you can hear cars or bikes coming up
behind you if someone were to call your
name
you could definitely hear it but it's
just not quite as good
as airpods if you've ever heard those
nevertheless battery is
eight hours with anc off five hours with
anc
on so that's pretty decent and then the
case gives you an extra 10 to 16 hours
and it'll also fast charge the buds and
give you an hour of listening time
in five minutes if you're nearly dead so
how do they
sound how do the latest beats by dre
in 2021 actually sound
i mean they sound fine but they
definitely still have
the the classic beats by dre sound
signature they've always had
basically even to my non-audiophile ears
they're not the best sounding earbuds
i've ever heard
but they are crisp and still have plenty
of bass
and highs but are much lighter on the
mids especially where vocals tend to be
basically it's not my preference for
sound profile
it works well with some genres of music
like hip hop but it does
feel like big chunks of the middle are
missing for a lot of other types of
music
they stay in my ears fairly well though
thanks to the silicone tips and they
create a nice seal i gotta have
soft tip earbuds for them to stay in my
ears i would not trust these to stay in
my ears for working out though like i
would trust things with
tips for example wing tips always just
thousand percent stay more snug in my
ear
the funny part though is anytime i skip
a song or
hold for assistant or do anything
involving clicking that outside button
on the bud i also end up pushing them a
little bit further into my ears
anyway which is maybe an unintentional
bonus but also
sometimes gets annoying overall though
i'd say i'm
basically baseline satisfied with how
these sound i leave them with anc on all
the time so that's kind of nice that
shortens the battery a bit of course
like i mentioned
but that's how they sound best they have
ipx4 water resistance too
so if i do work out with them there's no
worries about sweating a little bit or
walking through the rain or something
like that so these
are not the best overall i would give
that
to galaxy buds pro for best overall
package
or to sony's wf-1000
xm4 for just straight up sound quality
but these are cheaper and these are more
competitive than ever before but that's
that's really what happened is the
competition
woke up so yeah to anyone else who's
been watching beats
products over the last couple years this
is just a very
interesting it's a fascinating thing to
do to make a product that works just as
well
on android as it does for iphone like
for an apple owned company
it's pretty weird but that's more
competitive for all of us
and it's better for beats it's better
for us and so that
is the new beats they know the beats
name it's still big but it doesn't have
nearly the same pull in the headphone
world that it did like 10 years ago
like people aren't about to go out and
spend 400 bucks on
heavy clunky headphones that don't sound
that great
in 2021 like there's youtube reviews now
they would get called out
real fast but they're still perfectly
willing to send lebron james a pair
of these and you know it's free real
estate they're definitely still leaning
into the fashion part
but they're still around they're
changing it up a little bit and i like
where this is going
but also yes people did forget about dre
so thanks for watching also
channel sponsor dbrand has a new skin
and uh yeah it's wild
you might have seen it on the ps5 back
here it's called damascus so basically
did you know that
if you unlock everything in call of duty
warzone
the like final skin you can unlock is
this
wild damascus steel looking thing
there's some pretty sick youtube videos
of like unlocking it well this skin
is based on that plus there's a couple
different color ways there's a red
there's a green there's a triple black
of course
and a warzone blue which i'm going to
say i think i like just as much as the
matte black
and they're all on this crazy new
holographic material they design
in-house it kind of changes color as you
hold it at different
angles which is pretty sick or in the
case of the ps5 as you just
look at it from different parts of the
room in different light it's wild so you
can check them out at the link below
along with their brand new airpods cases
but that has been it
let me know what you guys think of this
new look beats by dre if you would buy
beats headphones for your android phone
today in 2021
that's been it thanks for watching catch
you guys later
peace